ministre des affaires étrangères john
baird serait sur le point de
démissionner ils marquent cette annonce
pourrait avoir lieu dès demain des
sources de cbis y confirme le départ de
john baird ce soir john baird qui
possiblement qu'il annoncera cette
semaine certainement et peut-être aussi
tôt que demain donc son départ de la vie
politique il ne sera pas candidat aux
prochaines élections
il démissionnera même de son poste de
ministre
donc au cours des prochains jours le
député de la région de tahoua et 1 il
faut dire là c'est très important un des
hommes forts
un des hommes de confiance de stephen
harper depuis 2006 depuis les
conservateurs ont pris le pouvoir ici à
ottawa
il est ministre les affaires étrangères
depuis mai 2011 c'est donc un gros
morceau du gouvernement en ontario qui
quittent quelques mois à peine avant les
prochaines élections et avant sa
carrière ou au fédéral il avait été je
vous le rappelle ministre du
gouvernement de mike harris en ontario
de 1995 à 2005 pourquoi démissionner
s'il ce n'est pas clair aucune certitude
sur les raisons de son départ
est ce qu'il y a par exemple un autre
poste qui l'attend ailleurs c'est la
question céline qu'on peut se poser ce
soir ouais on peut se poser la question
en effet est un autre dossier lié à
jangle parce que c'est lui qui l'a
annoncé c'est celui du journaliste
mohamed famille qui est emprisonné en
egypte et qui pourrait être libéré dans
les prochaines heures le voilà tout à
fait un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs john baird a indiqué que la
libération de mohamed fahmi donc ce
canadien d'origine égyptienne était
vraiment imminente ça veut dire que les
choses ont bougé et énormément au cours
des dernières heures d'ailleurs voici ce
que monsieur berda va dire un peu plus
tôt
voilà mohamed fahmi essentiellement
canado égyptien qui a été arrêté et
emprisonné par les autorités égyptiennes
avec deux autres collègues du réseau
anglais à jazeera il a été condamné à
sept ans de prison pour terrorisme mais
il ya environ un mois sa condamnation a
été renversé et hier céline il faut le
rappeler son collègue australien a été
libéré après plus de 400 jours de prison
et pour ce qui est du canadien donc pour
ce qui est de mohamed fahmi
ce ne serait plus qu'une question
d'heures mais il aura dû renoncer à sa
citoyenneté avant d'être relâchés et
quitter l'egypte il reste toujours un
troisième journaliste d'al jazeera
égyptien lui qui toujours emprisonnés et
on ne sait pas ce qui va lui arriver
merci beaucoup marque donc deux choses à
surveiller le départ de john baird et
peut-être cette libération de mohamed
fahmi
merci à suivre wouah